لا يرى مؤشرات اعلانيه روسيا استخداما
نووي رغم نقل 10 مقاتلات الى بيلاروسيا
اجتماع عسكري موسع في العاصمه الليبيه
للتامين حقول النفط واشنطن تقدم خطه لعشر
سنوات منعا للصراع
[موسيقى]
النظام السوري يدين الهجمات الامريكيه على
دير الزور وبايدن يقدم تبريراته
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد وهذه نشره
مفصله من العربيه ونبداها من تطورات الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث اثار قرار رئيس روسيا
فلاديمير بوت النقل اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
الى بيلاروسيا المجاوره لكل من اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا
اثارها هذا القرار مخاوف الغرب من توسع
رقعه الحرب وذلك ردا على خطط بريطانيا
لنقل قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم الى
اوكرانيا
وتعليقا على الخطوه الروسيه قالت وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه انه لا توجد مؤشرات على
ان روسيا تستعد لاستخدام اسلحه نوويه
وانها لم ترى اي سبب لتعديل وضع واشنطن
النووي الاستراتيجي الموقف الامريكي جاء
بعد اعلان الرئيس الروسي عن نشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه في روسيا البيضاء قبل ذلك
اعلن الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده ارسلت 10 مقاتلات لديها القدره على
حمل اسلحه نوويه الى بيلاروسيا واوضح
بوتين ان ارسال هذه الاسلحه لن ينتهك
المعاهده الدوليه او اتفاقيات عدم انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه
واشار بوتنهيل ان بلاده لا تنقل اسلحتها
النوويه الى بيلاروسيا بل تعيد تموضعها
كما فعلت امريكا في اوروبا وفق قوله
لا نعطي بيلاروسيا اسلحه نوويه بل ببساطه
ننقل اسلحتنا الى هناك مثل ما تفعل
الولايات المتحده منذ عقود لقد سلمنا
بالفعل لا بيلاروسيا منظومه اسكندر
المعروفه والفعاله للغايه في الثالث من
ابريل سنبدا تدريب الطاقه وفي الاول من
يوليو سننتهي من بناء منشاه تخزين خاصه
للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه على اراضي
بيلاروسيا
اعلان بوتين ياتي بعد تاكيد رئيس الاركان
الاوكراني
ان قوات بلاده تمكنت من تحقيق الاستقرار
في مدينه متولتي شهدت اعنف المعارك مدن
دراع الحرب وقال زغني على حسابه في فيسبوك
ان التحقيق الاستقرار جاء بفضل جهود
القوات الاوكرانيه من جهتها اكدت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه في بيان لها انه من
المرجح ان يكون التفوق الاوكراني في
المنطقه جاء نتيجه الاستنزاف الشديد
للقوات الروسيه والتي تتكبد خسائر بشريه
فادحه حسبما اورده البيان البريطاني
قال وزير خارجي المجري في التي تظهر بلاده
تقاربا مع موسكو قال ان انتقاد الغرب
المستمر لبلاده بشان القضايا الديمقراطيه
والثقافيه يجعل الحكومه متردده في تقديم
الدعم في الامور العمليه وتحديدا
وفي مقابله اوضح وزير خارجي المجري ان
بلاده لم تصوت على السماح الفنلندا
والسويد بانضمام الى الناتو لان المشرعين
المجريين سائموا من انتقادات تلك الدول
للشؤون الداخليه المجريه مضيفا رفض بلاده
لتشكيك السياسيين الفنلنديين والسويديين
في طبيعه النظام الديمقراطي المجري
تنطلق صباح اليوم في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري اخر
ملفات مرحله نهائيه من العمليه السياسيه
الجاريه في البلاد منذ توقيع الاتفاق
الاطار
وستضمن توصيات الورشه في الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي الذي ينتظر ان يسلم اليوم من قبل
اللجنه المشتركه من العسكريين والمدنيين
وتناقش الورشه دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
الجيش وفق جدول زمني يتفق عليه ودمج
الفصائل المسلحه وفقا للبند المنصوص عليه
في اتفاق جبر السلام الورشه التي ستستمر
حتى الاربعاء المقبل يتوقع ان تخرج بخريطه
طريق تساعد في ترتيبات الاصلاح في
القطاعات الامنيه والنظاميه وهي الجيش
والدعم السريع والشرطه والامن
قبل ذلك اكد المتحدث الرسمي باسم المجلس
المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير جعفر حسن
الانتهاء من صياغه مسوده نهائيه لاتفاق
السياسي وقال في مؤتمر الصحفي ان مسوده
الاتفاق السياسي اكتملت نهائيا وستسلم
اليوم للمواقعين عند التاسعه مساء مشيرا
الى ان الحريه والتغيير ستلتزم بالمواقيت
النهائيه العمليه السياسيه التي ستنتهي
بتشكيل الحكومه في الحادي عشر من ابريل
المقبل
تم اكمال مسوده الاتفاق السياسي النهائي
وستسلم يوم غد
لكل
الموقعين سواء كانوا مدنيين او عسكريين
عند التاسعه مساء بالقصر الجمهوري سيتم
تسليم المسوده لكل طرف حتى يكون بشكل
نهائي كله طرف ابدا موافقته النهائيه لان
اللجنه ظلت تعمل ليل نهار بواقع جلستين في
اليوم لاكمال هذه المسوده حتى نلتزم
بالمواقيت التي ضربناها في تواريخها واحد
ابريل وسته ابريل و11 ابريل لكي تقوم
مواقيت نهائيه كما امن المجلس على
التاكيد على هذه المواقيت والالتزام بها
وهذا لزم من اللجنه ان تستمر ليله نهار
لعقد هذا الامر
في المقابل جددت الكتله الديمقراطيه رفضها
العمليه السياسيه وقال الناطق باسمها محمد
زكريا في مقابله مع العربيه ان تشكيل
حكومه بل حكومه معارضه موازيه خيار وارد
بالنسبه لي الحريه واللا تغيير الكتله
الديمقراطيه ولن تكون هذه الحكومه قصرا
اعلن الكتله اللا ديمقراطيه وانما ايضا ما
يجري من عمليه سياسيه وجدت الرفض عريض من
قوى الثوريه حيه من على سبيل المثال منها
حزب البعث الحزب العشوائي هناك التيار
الجزري هناك قوى لجانة لمقاومه سنعمل على
ان نلتقي مع هذه اللاقوه على ارضيه مشتركه
اتناقش هموم الوطن ونؤسس لحكومه على الاقل
بقاعده عريضه اليست حكومه اقليه هذا واحد
من الخيارات ولكن دعيني اؤكد اننا لا دلنا
نقول ان ابوابنا مفتوحه للحوار
نشاطنا مستمر وفيها بعض الفاصل
وسط توتر مع الصين جزيره تايوان تتعرض
لانتكاسه جديده وتفقد اعترافهم دوراس بها
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد ادانت وزاره
الخارجيه السعوديه قرار اسرائيل نشر
عطاءات لبناء وحدات الاستيطانيه داخل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه واكدت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان قرار اسرائيل يعد استمرار على
الانتهاكات الصارخه من جانب سلطتها واكدت
الرياضه على ضروره اطلاع المجتمع الدولي
بمسؤولياته لانهاء الاحتلال ووقفي
ممارساته الاستفزازيه
وكانت الخارجيه الاردنيه بدورها اذان
الطرحه اسرائيل عطاءات لبناء اكثر من الف
وحده استيطانيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
مؤكده ان تلك النشاطات الاستيطانيه تعد
خرقا فاضحا للقانون الدولي وتقويضا لاسس
السلام وجهود تحقيقه وفورص حل الدولتين
كما شددت الخارجيه الاردنيه على ان
الممارسات الاحاديه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل
غير شرعيه ولا قانونيه وهي مرفوضه ومدامه
هذا وكان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي تقداع
الى تعليق التعديلات في الوقت الحالي
وايضا الى وقف التظاهرات
الابيه غير مسبوقه مشيرا الى ان عمق
الانقسام الداخلي حول تعديل النظام
القضائي هو خطر دائم على امن البلاد
من اجل امن اسرائيل من اجل ابنائنا
وبناتنا يجب ايقاف العمليه التشريعيه في
هذا الوقت السماح لشعب اسرائيل بالاحتفال
بعيد الفصح وعيد الاستقلال معا
ولنحزن معا في يوم الذكرى ويوم الهولوكوست
هذه ايام مقدسه بالنسبه لنا
نحن بحاجه الى وقف المظاهرات والاحتجاجات
والتواصل من اجل الحوار اي مظهر من مظاهر
التردد الذي ينال من قوه جيش الدفاع
الاسرائيلي ويضر بالنظام الامني يجب ان
يتوقف على الفور من اجل امننا ومن اجل
وحدتنا من واجبنا العوده الى ساحه الحوار
على الارض اندلعت مواجهات بين متظاهرين
والمئات من اسرار العكود الذين وصلوا الى
شارع كابلان في تل ابيب ورددوا هتافات ضد
المحتجين في شوارع ومدن اسرائيل رفضا لخطه
تغيير نظام القضائي مع دفع الشرطه للتدخل
ومحاوله فض المواجهات من خلال استخدام
خراطيم المياه
دعنا النظام السوري الهجمات الامريكيه على
دير الزهور متعهد بانهاء الاحتلال
الامريكي على حد تعبيره في وقت قال رئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن في رساله
الامريكيه الاخيره في سوريا كانت موجهه
لمنشات تستخدمها جماعات تابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني في القياده والسيطره
وتخزين الذخائر واوضح بايدن ان القوات
الامريكيه استهدفت منشات في شرق سوريا ردا
على الهجمات الاخيره والتهديدات المستمره
بشن هجمات في المستقبل مشيرا الى انه امر
بتوجيه الضربات الخميس الماضي من اجل
الحمايه والدفاع عن سلامه الافراد
الامريكيين واضعاف وتعطيل سلسله الهجمات
المستمره ضد الولايات المتحده وشركائها
واكد بايدن ان قرار شن ضربات الاخيره في
سوريا كان ضروريا ويتفق مع القانون الدولي
ضمن ممارسه الولايات المتحده لحقها في
الدفاع عن نفسه وانا ضربات الامريكيه
الاخيره في سوريا جاءت بهدف الرضع وتجنب
بل تجنبت وقوع ضحايا بين صفوف المدني ين
وبعد يومين من قصف صاروخي استهدف قاعده
امريكيه في محطه دير الزور شرق سوريا بدات
قوات تابعه للجيش العراقي التحرك على على
المناطق الحدوديه مع سوريا بهدف سد
الثغرات الامنيه بين البلدين وافادت مصادر
صحفيه للشرق الاوسط بل افادت مصادر صحيفه
الشرق الاوسط بان قوات من الجيش في محافظه
الانبار الغربيه العراق والمتاخمه لسوريا
بحدود طويله بدات عمليات استطلاع ميداني
على مناطق الشريط الحدودي مع سوريا
في لبنان الى جانب ازمات صرف الدولار
وغلاء المعيشه ينشغل اللبنانيون هذه
الايام بمعضله جديده اسمها تاجير التوقيت
الصيفي ازمه اثارت الغضب والسخريه في ان
واحد نتابع
هكذا وبدردشه بينهما قرر رئيس البرلمان
والحكومه تاجيل العمل بالتوقيت الصيفي حتى
نهايه شهر رمضان المبارك قرار رسم مشهدا
استرياليا على الحياه اللبنانيه بردود
الفعل عليه يعني هالقد في بزنس وشغل
بلبنان لحتى الساعه تاثر عليها
لنشوف شو بدنا نعمل لانه عم نشتغل نحن
كمان مع بره وفي سفر قد يعتبره البعض
موضوعا سخيفا الا انه فتح باب الطائفيه
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لتبدا
الاتهامات باسلمه النظام السياسي ليرد
عليها بعدم احترام العيش المشترك فيما
تبقى المشكله الاساسيه فوض القرارات
والتفرد بها وفي حكم ما في الساعه موقفه
من زمان عنا سواء اخر همه حبيبي
عده عدم الالتزام بقرار مجلس الوزراء
واعلنت انها ستبدا بالعمل بالتوقيت الصيفي
في وقته الاساسي كشركات ومطاعم ومدارس
ومؤسسات اعلاميه فيما شركه الطيران الشرق
الاوسط الطره الى تعديل مواعيد كل رحلاتها
بعد البلبله التي حصلت اهدى اول شيء اما
لا يتعلق بتدبير حكومي وانما
ما فينا نلتزم باذى لانه كل الدراسات
العالميه بتشير انه على الاقل بدك سنه قبل
لحتى تبلغي الجهات المعنيه وخصوصا الجهات
المعنيه بالتوقيت انه هي بلغيها الذي يمكن
ان يتخذ ثم نحنا منتضر كتير من هالامر
لانه نحن عنا ارتباطات بمشاهدين بكل انحاء
العالم احدى العائلات سترسل ابنها الى
مدرسته في التوقيت الاول وبعدها الساعه
سترسل ابنها الاخر الى مدرسه اخرى بعد ان
امتد الخلاف الى المدارس هي عينه من
الضياع الذي سيعيشه اللبنانيون مع وجود
التوقيتين في بلدهم ففي بلدان العالم هناك
توقيت غرينتش اما في لبنان فتوقيت صيفي او
توقيت بري او توقيت ميقاتي وحتى توقيت
اسلامي او مسيحي لبنان الذي في الاساس
اصبح خارج الزمن بازماته باتت ساعه من هذا
الزمن كفيله باشعاله طائفيا وكان الشعب
يعيش حياه ورديه ستؤثر عليها ساعه مقدمه
او مؤخره نهج يوسف العربيه بيروت
في ليبيا اكد مصدر عسكري للعربي وصول رئيس
الاركان العام التابع للجيش الليبي عبد
الرزاق الناظوري الى طرابلس واضاف المصدر
ان ناظوري وصل رفقه اعضاء لجنه 5 + 5
لاستكمال المباحثات التي جرت في تونس
الايام الماضيه برعايه الامم المتحده ومن
اهم ملفات التي ستناقش في الاجتماع الذي
يلقى دعما امريكيا كبيرا انشاء قوه مشتركه
بين الشرق والغرب والجنوب وتامين اجراء
الانتخابات
هذا هو اعلن المبعوث الامريكيه الخاصيه
ليبيا عن استراتيجيه الامريكيه جديده لعشر
سنوات في ليبيا لمنع الصراع ودعم
الانتخابات وفقا لحساب السفاره الامريكيه
على تويتر وقال انه استراتيجيه واشنطن
تعتمد على شركات بناءه وبرامج على مستوى
المجتمع لدعم تطلعات الشعب الليبي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والمساءله والحوكمه كما اشار
المبعوث الامريكي لدى ليبيا الى ان هذه
المبادره تؤكد التزام الولايات المتحده
بالوقوف الى جانب الشعب الليبي ودعم
التقدم نحو حكومه الموحده منتخب
الديمقراطيا يمكنها تقديم الخدمات العامه
وتعزيز نمو الاقتصادي في جميع المجالات
اخر اتهمت منظمه اس اوروبيه غير الحكوميه
اتهمت خفر السواحل الليبي بتعريض طاقم
سفينتها
قارب للخطر بشكل متعمد خلال تنفيذ عمليه
انقاذ وقالت المنظمه الانسانيه التي تتخذ
من مدينه مارسيليا الفرنسيه مقر لها قالت
ان جميع محاولات الاتصال بمقر خفر السواحل
الليبي باءت بالفشل في وقت بدا فيه خفر
السواحل الليبي التصرفها بشكل عدائي على
حد تعبير المنظمه مهددين بالسلاح ومطلقين
عده اعين في الهواء تجاه السفينه ووفقا
للمنظمه للمنظمه اهتم في النهايه اعتراض
نحو 80 شخصا من قبل خفر السواحل الليبي
واعادتهم الى ليبيا
في ملف الهجره ايضا لقي تسعه عشر مهاجرا
على الاقل من دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
حتفهم عندما غرق قارب قاربهم قباله تونس
اثناء محاوله عبور البحر المتوسط الى
ايطاليا وذلك حسبما افادت منظمه حقوقيه
تونسيه وخيار الايام الاربعه الماضيه غرقت
خمسه قوارب للمهاجرين قبارة مدينه صفاقس
الجنوبيه ما اسفر عن وفاه تسعه وفقدان
سبعه وستين وذلك بعد زياده كبيره في عدد
القوارب المتجهه نحو ايطاليا
اكدت الشرطه الالمانيه سقوط قتيلين بعد
اطلاق نار وقع في مدينه هامبورج واضافت ان
العمليه ذات الصله انتهت الا انها فتحت
تحقيقا واحجمت الشرطه عن ذكر اي تفاصيل
تتعلق بمطلق النهر كما رجحت مراسله
العربيه رجحت ان الحادثه ليس مرتبطا
بعمليه ارهابيه
انتكاسه جديده تعرضت لها تايوان الساعيه
الاستقلال عن الصيد حيث تراجعت هندوراس
وتتحول نحو بكين في هذا السياق قالت وكاله
انباء الصين الجديده ان الصين اقامتا
علاقات دبلوماسيه وذلك بعد قطع الاخيره
علاقاتها الدبلوماسيه مع تايوان واشارت
الوكاله الى ان الصين وعند دورات اتفقتا
على تطوير العلاقات على اساس مبادئ
الاحترام المتبادل للسياده والسلام
الاقليميه بدورها وصفت وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه قرار هندوراس قطع العلاقات مع
تايوان بانه قرار سياسي بل سيادي مشيره في
الوقت ذاته الى اهميه الانتباه الى الوعود
التي غالبا ما تقدمها الصين مقابل
الاعتراف الدبلوماسي بانها في نهايه
المطاف فيما اعتبر وزير خارج التايواني ان
رئيسه هندوراس زيومارا كاسترو تساورها
اوهام بشان وعود الصين لها بتقديم مساعدات
اقتصاديه مضيفا ان الصين لم تكف عن محاوله
اغراء هندوراس عبر حوافز ماليه
بمناسبه ساعه الارض اطفات العديد من
المعالم الشهيره حول العالم انوارها
للتوعيه بضروره الحفاظ على الكوكب ساعه
الارض حدث عالمي يقام في كل عام في اخر
سبت من شهر مارس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في نهايه النفس مشاهدينا نذكر بالعناوين
البنتاجون لا يرى مؤشرات علانيه روسيا
استخداما نووي رغم نقل 10 مقاتلات الى
بيلاروسيا
اجتماع عسكري موسع في العاصمه الليبيه
للتامين حقول النفط واشنطن تقدم خطه لعشر
سنوات منعا للصراع
[موسيقى]
النظام السوري يدين الهجمات الامريكيه على
دير الزور وبيض يقدم تبريراته للكونجرس
نهايه هذه النشر مشاهدينا كونوا بعافيه
[موسيقى]